please welcome our silver medal award
winners and animation I say a powers and
Jeremy Casper oh hello this is this is
absolutely incredible we spent about
eight months in a basement with three of
my best friends pretty much working on a
film and it's just incredible I want to
thank the academy for bringing us out
here for recognizing like what we have
accomplished and given us the engine
that they have we're from Kansas City
Missouri and it's just crazy I wanna I
wanna yeah it is I'd like to recognize
Stewart beery he was a third filmmaker
on her film co-director writer if he
could stand up please give him a round a
round of applause thank you and I'd also
like to thank his wife Lori for the
support for supporting him in us in this
film so it's a lot of work it's a lot of
dedication um I also want to thank my
mom for the work she put in chi to the
costume design for us it'd be possible
it wouldn't look as beautiful as it did
without that and for Regina Weller for
working on this film with us she helped
an incredible amount with painting and
coloring and building all the amazing
detail that we have and I'd also like to
thank our musician max justice for his
work on this because it wouldn't be the
same without the music he's a genius too
well first I'd like to also thank the
Academy and just yeah like I say I said
just for brain is out here being a part
of this meeting all the great people
being part of this community and we've
got to give it up to our our professor
Doug Hudson who created this program we
have an animation program in the Midwest
which is amazing thing and then also
another department faculty member Steve
Mays who who actually came down and into
our basement and helped us construct
some of the sets so and I have to also
thank my parents for being extremely
supportive and everything that I've ever
wanted to accomplish and also my wife
who had to give it up to her the most
because we were just recently married
when we started this film and so she
spent many of nights alone so i have to
thank her very much for her her support
thank you all